les hommes sont impressionnés par le
fait que je suis quelqu'un de populaire
et là c'est c'est atroce la séduction
c'est toujours de dire non
de faire comprendre que oui mais de dire
non et de toute façon ça ça s'est déjà
vu plusieurs fois
plus on résiste à un mec
plus il craque pour vous jamais être
dominé en fait parce que lorsque je
domine l'homme ne m'intéresse plus c'est
ça et c'est tout le contraire en fait de
l'image que je donne parce que je donne
une image de quelqu'un qui domine et qui
aime dominer alors que c'est tout c'est
tout l'inverse et c'est lorsqu'un homme
sait me prendre comme ça et me dit tu
arrêtes maintenant je veux dire que je
crains donc j'ai besoin d'être dominé
mais dominer n'est peut-être pas le vrai
mot en fait parce que c'est ridicule de
dire d'abdominé je suis pas quelqu'un
qui va fait qui va laver les chaussettes
de son mec absolument pas il y a des
machines à laver pour ça et c'est lui
qui la met en route et
si un homme essaie de vous garder pour
lui que vous réagissez
ah j'aime bien
ah oui il faut qu'il essaie de me garder
moi je veux être la chose la plus
importante pour pour cet homme je veux
je veux devenir bon donc il faut il faut
qu'il essaie de me garder pour lui et
pour et pour qu'il me garde pour lui il
faut vraiment qu'ils bosse comme un
malade un mec qui se laisse aller
simplement parce que ça y est il m'a
acquise et tout ça c'est un mec qui me
perd tout de suite
et vous vous continuez à le séduire mais
est-ce que vous continuez à séduire
d'autres hommes jamais ah non j'ai dit
tout à l'heure je suis fidèle
ah oui ah quoique bon un petit peu comme
ça
avant
je suis fidèle dans le jambon je séduis
juste avec le regard comme ça et puis
bon c'est c'est sympa de penser en fait
tiens il aimerait bien mais il peut pas
parce que de toute façon je lui
appartiens déjà à quelqu'un et je suis
très très possessive moi je sais pas je
pourrais claquer s'il se passe quelque
chose quoi même si s'il a le le malheur
de regarder une autre femme je le claque
ah vous lui permettez pas ce que vous
permettez à vous
je ne peux pas regarder
lui peut pas regarder moi je regarde
mais je regarde toujours d'un oeil
discret à partir du moment où le type
qui est avec moi regarde les fesses
d'une autre femme c'est que bon les
miennes ne lui suffisent plus et ça je
ne le supporte pas les mots c'est
important la parole
ben oui les mots sont ouais les mots
sont importants je crois que les regards
sont plus importants j'attribue beaucoup
plus d'importance à tous les regards
c'est on peut dire tellement de choses à
travers le regard que je crois que c'est
ça qui est plus important que les mots
parce que les mots en fait vous semblent
très grand lorsque vous avez envie de
les dire une fois que vous les avez dit
il semble tout petit
c'est ce que j'ai remarqué
quand on veut dire je t'aime un type bon
au moment de le ressentir et de le dire
avant de le dire je veux dire on a
l'impression que c'est quelque chose
d'énorme et au moment où on le dit c'est
tout petit ça prend
cinq syllabes c'est tout alors que bon
je veux dire par rapport à ce qu'on
ressent c'est c'est minuscule est-ce que
vous le dites facilement ça je t'aime
non non je l'ai très très rarement dit
parce qu'en fait j'ai mis très peu
vous savez c'est pas facile d'aimer je
crois que c'est une chose qu'on apprend
et qu'on apprend pas lorsqu'on est très
jeune je crois que c'est avec une
certaine maturité qu'on apprend vraiment
ce que c'est que que l'amour avec un
grand teint ah oui c'est c'est je suis
tout à fait bien dans ma peau c'est vrai
que je ne suis pas la femme idéale je
suis pas grande j'ai pas les nichons que
Madonna et tout ça bon alors je fais
avec moi-même donc c'est quand je passe
je pense pas être une des femmes bon
peut-être aujourd'hui parce que je suis
jamais c'est tout mais c'est je suis pas
une femme qu'on regarde comme ça en
faisant mars
on dit pas ça de moi les hommes sont
impressionnés par le fait que je suis
quelqu'un de populaire et là c'est c'est
atroce
pour vous non c'est que là il craque
tout de suite c'est affreux
donc il y a même plus le goût de jouer
et de dire bon jusqu'à jusqu'à quel
point je vais pouvoir arriver et c'est
pas bien
vous avez l'air d'y croire en tout cas
vous savez que je drague beaucoup moins
maintenant qu'avant
parce que maintenant je sais même plus
si on me veut moi parce que je suis
jeanne Mas ou moi parce que je suis une
femme c'est vachement dur mais
bon je me considère pas une femme qui a
tous les mecs à ses pieds et puis ça ne
m'intéresse même pas je veux dire ça
sert à quoi
vous aimeriez non non parce que
justement je trouve que ça sert à rien
et que avoir plusieurs mecs qui ne vous
donne absolument rien je pense qu'on en
avoir un qui vous donne tout c'est
largement suffisant et puis c'est la
chose la plus belle lorsque j'entends
parler mais ex de moi
c'est très drôle de leur dire en fait
c'est c'est de leur entendre dire bon
qu'il faut énormément de patience
[Rires]
de tomber comme ça dans vos filets
il va falloir demander je sais qu'il y
en a certains qui sont parmi
et c'est drôle oui ça vous a vu
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]